taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey welcome to cheese
Buds and today today today we got the
guys from we're pieces of here
that's only when you're on it LaRosa
the show what's a show where everybody's
a piece of garbage now are you going
towards your heels
thank you thank you Joe thank you for
having me fun one to be on I just you
guys just had me it came out yesterday
actually yes I believe so awesome guys
thank you so much your other episode
that you did with us you did one or two
episodes actually I think we did too oh
yeah those two of my favorites yeah we
all believed in what we were fighting
for it just really went well this is my
favorite show this is what I would do
with all of my time if I could because
you just argues sandwiches and stuff
I'll give you a key I'll give you a key
come on here and join us anytime this is
what we did and that's why we turned
into a podcast
yeah oh it's great now you guys are
great yeah
yeah yeah man and is this the most we've
ever had guests on three yeah I think or
three times
he doesn't he does everybody's podcast
every two weeks last night I'm on
Instagram
but yeah yeah oh yeah Q yeah Q's yeah uh
I'm on Instagram last night I'm
scrolling
let's see Legion of skanks tonight I'm
like Ari are you just part of the show
sure yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel
like he's on it every two weeks shout
out to Ari Shaffer Ari Shaffer
uh we're here today now we'll get to it
but let's start yelling at each other
pleasantries
I mean you're coming in here tanned up I
mean you're looking good you're looking
sure thank you yes I feel like you like
I don't know something that might tell
you you mean business celio's Pizza
you do look you do look slick today
thanks you do you look like you're ready
to go thank you and I'll tell you we're
doing a first today okay this today this
battle is me versus everything
I was like there's no way Sal is against
Elios you know and I know it's a gang up
but I I didn't want to Overstock
foreign
just now and Sal goes so goes well babe
what are we gonna do I mean they're
Elio's I'm Elio so I go I'll go
that's actually how he said it and I was
like dude I don't know what you want to
do because I'm illios and he goes I
don't give a he goes I'll take on
all of you that's how he said it's just
me in the kitchen
the uh okay we'll get to it I'm not
surprised by the way that you two
especially like Elio yes
on the floor
you bum them all for me
I saw you guys at the Stefanos where
this boy them all over here
yeah
[Laughter]
if you were a cigarette you would be
bench
I swear to God I'd be capris
you're gonna love this works
Winston lights
my grandpa used to smoke unfiltered
camels she's wild yeah it's wild right
yeah that's unfiltered people this is
what I love about the garbage guys
I'm not breaking balls I'm saying this
for real you guys don't give a
you guys walked in I go all right guys
what's up you go good to see you we're
gonna have a smoke we'll be right
save me one of them sandwiches I'll be
right back
no it's so funny you say that dude I was
I was up in Boston I went to this like
Dive Bar dive it's like Sully
O'Sullivan's Tap House yeah everybody's
doing like you know drugs it's just like
a there's something you would see out of
like the town and I'm in there and I'm
drinking a guy kids see me they're like
holy are you garbage we love the
show like what are you doing here I'm
like this is where I drink
I'm not inside
martinis or something what do you think
of playing a character
yeah no man that's the best but go to
the flip side of that the last time you
guys were on uh we were a different
location you showed up with pastries
yeah we did
yeah anytime we go to a house if we're
going over someone's records at their
house or somewhere or something we show
up with a gift I'll never forget but
that is a garbage thing that is
something that you think so it's not
that's something that uh like you know
like poorer people would do you got to
bring something you can't come
empty-handed yeah yeah so yeah yeah
yeah
it's funny because I oh I over I've
overdone it with that first time I went
to your house remember I brought all
those Entenmann's cakes it was
ridiculous it was crazy too many games I
bought like three headsets like three
bags of cookies I brought all this stuff
because I didn't want to show up
empty-handed and then I just went down
to Austin
uh for tone Bell's birthday and I flew
down to to surprise him on the road they
did a rose for him so I did that and
then he had a party on Saturday at his
place and I showed up to the party and
go dude I'm so sorry I've showed up
empty-handed and he was like well I
taught you is you flew to Austin
but I was like I have that dude I feel
like if I walk in I'm like you have to
at least have a six-pack or something
you gotta have something
it's a nice gesture but I think it's
born out of like if you feel like I have
to get like I'm taking from I don't want
to be taking from you go to somebody's
house for like a party or dinner or
whatever it is you bring a bottle of
wine and a bottle of wine that's not for
the party put this aside that's for you
guys for later okay so yes do it I do
that all the time I've been late because
I've been like I don't have anything and
I have to stop to get it right sure what
about this though feels good it feels
good it feels good it's good to walk in
there and hit a home run yeah 100 you
have you ever bring a nice bottle of
wine and uh and and and then do you know
that they don't know it's a nice bottle
of wine I always I always
put that away for later don't give it
everything
that's first yeah the only reason I'm
doing any of this is for the face throws
a good person I'm a piece of yeah
bottle of wine
anyway 30 bucks enough sorry sure you
know what I mean like well we're all so
trashy like you know we you know we
started making money and now we go over
the top because we don't know so we're
like oh yeah I'll give you something
that's 300. a 20 bottle of wine would
suffice I just dropped 200 on a JV
soccer team for a fundraiser boom let's
go
I'm stupid
dude that's such a funny concept of a of
a guy getting a little a trashy guy
giving a little bit of money but it does
rip the the cheap version of rich guy
things like he buys like a little league
team instead of buying like an NFL team
dude
fun we were talking about opening a bar
just so we could have a softball team
I got a bar if you're interested come
take it over the real easy side switch
yo what about a joey Rose's softball
team we should that'd be awesome that'd
be a good time we did we did a we did uh
Finance yeah guest Bartender the other
thing did he oh yeah
the door's still open for you uh the Ian
guest bartended and uh he uh
Tia Joanna Joanna Angel who works in
adult film came in to hang out she's
going to do one too because she said
that very serious words but she's
sitting at the bar you recalibrated them
yeah the angel of course the steamed yes
CPA Person of Interest we did a video of
him he was like I'm gonna make you an
Ian Finance Margarita and it was the
joke was that it was awful it was like
whiskey and pickle juice whatever
because he doesn't know how to do it
and he's we'd shoot this video and then
Joanna sent it to me
and uh the video is Ian going he's
shaking the drink and Joanna goes I
don't know Ian that doesn't look very
good and he goes take it easy Joanna I
don't come to your job and tell you how
many cups screaming it right so I go Ian
I can't put this on the thing sure on
the feed and he goes why not it's funny
and I go
you screaming violently at a woman not
really the brand sure it's not so far
with the sandwiches right it's not
really yeah it's not really the brand
for the bar
um come to Joey Rose you know what dumb
are always welcome
cut this story
seriously just cut the story away
he did something that went nowhere on
the list
[Applause]
keep going with it
I was trying to say like yeah because
you because maybe you want to sponsor a
softball team or something with with
your bar or whatever and it's it's
he said little league and I was like
yeah sometimes you want to sponsor a
little league team with your bar that
reminds me of the time I totally in
finance I could have him screaming why
didn't you tell it like that
last that was better than the one he did
last time last episode he goes ah my
Uber I used to live in this building uh
that you couldn't access the building
through the garage so you had to go to
the garage when you got in and when I
would get the Uber they pull up
especially female drivers they would
never want to go into the garage
we'll be right back with sports
show well this leads me to the dig that
I want to get in on challenge yeah sure
I like this this is like couples I got
back up today because you gotta you got
voice memos from last night oh yeah
classic South this was classic you last
night it was so funny dude
ciao fair and I'll finish you you like
to really ruminate and think right you
like to analyze you're an analytical guy
in general yes yes pontificator yeah
yeah I was texting with Kevin about the
episode in two Xiao sends me some
suggestions I hit Kevin in two seconds
we figure it out he's like ilios yeah
baby let's go I was like ilios versus
Hot Pockets
[Laughter]
I go this is so easy this is so easy we
figured it out and then as I'm about to
sit at the cell I'm like
God damn it this isn't going to be sure
as easy as I think I said it oh my God
they want to do Elio's versus Hot
Pockets
three dots boom boom they're rolling
immediately pops up three minute 45 3
minute 45 second voice memo
be honest and I'll pull it up I got
receipts I haven't crossed over to the
voice memos oh and you're not allowed to
with me just saying and I'm like and I
hit play he's like you know babe I don't
know it's just we talked about Elio's
last time and I just think it actually
you know I got the receipts why didn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't I say what happened
yeah that's good so I sent him a bunch
of suggestions the thing when he came
back with Helios I said only one thing
is I remember we discussed Elio's lesson
I'm sure I just want to make sure it
wasn't part of the battle we didn't
cover it a lot sure that's the only
thing I really said but he we're going
back and forth back on the first person
to leave a voice memo was Joe DeRosa no
that's not true you sent me one that I
didn't keep no no no no no no no that's
not true all right well you hit me with
a two minute and 31 seconds that was in
response to one or two that you had
already said all right so he hit me with
a 231 okay I hit him back that's a
chunky message crazy yeah it's way
longer than attack I've gotten 12 minute
ones from here no we do that with each
other yeah
because I'm doing stuff as I'm saying
I do I do concur with that yeah but he
hits me he calls me goes what do you got
I go that's not how this relationship
works you don't call me and go what do
you got I like to check I like to chit
chat then he'd bring something to the
table
let you and me start I hit you with a
124 after that and then a subsequent 32.
your original your original 112 your
inaugural voice memos are not on there
and it's not fair because it's painting
a slanted picture here I can only make a
judgment on the evidence that I have but
yeah I did laugh because I was listening
to his message and I said and we were
talking about
different cuts of fries so seriously
sure but I was like I'm gonna play this
on the Pod tomorrow
I love that too
I love that yeah
it's also for people there are people
out there that think
we amp it up for the show or we're not
really disinvested this is proof of
houses we went back and forth with like
50 texts I love this yeah here we go
especially when I have a guests like
either
first of all I think even if we only had
two rounds it would be plenty because we
haven't seen each other in a while I
wasn't on the last two episodes
fill me in like oh when Eric was here
this was set or whatever and all that
I want to talk about Gato doing his
impression to me whatever I think two
battles is going to be more than enough
but if you want to have three uh a fry
you did not mention is the crinkle cut
and the crinkle cut to me is like a
scientist heavy hitting fry I think it
is the unsung hero french fries
it makes a difference uh I don't
necessarily know why but it is a
different I get excited
so we could do crinkle cut shoestring
which is the tradition
uh sweet potato
uh waffle
steak fries and then also potato wedges
but potato wedges and steak fries might
be a wash I think potato wedges are
heinous I think steak fries are often
problematic and I think sweet potatoes
uh so I got plenty to say and I think we
got plenty there
um I would really say like if we just
picked the best two
I think that that's really fine
uh for garbage
I will Circle back and say to Kevin hey
apparently we talked about Elios a lot
last time look he he lit up it at hot
pressed pretzels too I think pitting the
soft pretzel against something is good
they're from Philly Soft Pretzel is a
big Philly traditional food it's trashy
they sell them on the highway
and on the street yeah you know it's
it's street food like vendors sell them
cars so I think soft pretzels the work
I would dare say that soft pretzel
versus Hot Pocket could even be a thing
I think soft pretzel would get clobbered
but
um well you're nuts so I can go back and
add some pretzels if they're lit up by
yeah
as much
I don't know maybe reading too much into
his text but maybe I'm reading
it
was like a forward text I was like Dude
Love soft pretzels love this maybe I'm
reading doing too far into it you
weren't seeing the other side of it I
know I'm getting bro I'm getting barrage
from South I just pictured the Roses
apartment with like red red yarn
pretzels
I think
um if we could if I could just say guys
we love game time on this show and we
started using this app and they are last
minute tickets with the best deals
guaranteed I stopped the way I purchased
tickets I use this app and sometimes now
I'll look for events going on in my you
know in my area like that night which I
never shopped that way before they have
it for concerts they have sporting
events Broadway shows everything you can
think of playoff games okay killer last
minute deals you get the view from your
seat
um a best price guarantee uh game time
takes the guesswork out of buying
tickets
[Music]
um
you buy tickets in seconds which is two
tabs and what I like about is it gets
sent to your phone so you're not
searching through the email once you get
to the event I love that about it too
and the game time guarantee means you'll
always get the best price if you find
tickets in the same section and row for
Less game time will credit you 110 of
the difference take the guesswork out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code taste buds for twenty dollars
off your first purchase term Supply
again create an account redeem code
t-a-s-t-e-b-u-d-s taste buds for twenty
dollars off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed guys tickets from my special
in Chicago on December 2nd went on sale
last week and they sold out uh on the
first day because of you guys I am so
grateful uh that we are going to add
another two shows but that is it I'm not
editing any more than this but this is
the huge announcement right now they
went on sale on Friday
um we are going to do Friday December
1st as well tickets are on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com com they are
on sale you don't even need a promo code
I am not adding more shows after this
the first two sold out immediately so if
you were waiting or thinking about
getting tickets
Friday December 1st those are on sale at
sabalcano comedy.com and I will say
because I've been being asked a lot
the contest still stands if you are
going to any of my tapings any of the
four tapings for my uh stand up comedy
special I'm going to choose one ticket
it doesn't matter where you sit and it
doesn't matter what taping you're at I'm
going to choose one person give you a
plus one I'm going to fly you to New
York put you up in a hotel and bring you
on a set of Impractical Jokers I want to
do that as a thank you to you guys
because I couldn't believe it sold out
so fast so you're still in it to win it
if you buy a ticket savocano comedy.com
right now Friday December 1st at the Vic
in Chicago if you have a friend that
lives in Chicago around that area let
them know again I'm going to pick one
person out of those tapings it doesn't
matter where you sit so grab those right
away the rest of the tour is also still
on sale with tons of dates
um as a matter of fact this coming
weekend I will be in uh
Bowling Green Kentucky uh Cincinnati
Ohio and Toledo and then we're moving on
to Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware in October we have
Macon Savannah and Athens Georgia and
even more and more dates all them up
right now on sale at
seattlecountercomedy.com the Impractical
Jokers cruise is January 22nd to the
26th with Eric Andre with Stevo and
we're announcing tons of more Comedians
and bands this coming week there's only
a few cabins left for that you can go
get those at get ship faced haha
cruise.com that's get shipfacecrews.com
check out nopresh.com
noprushnetwork.com from Merchant
savalkano comedy.com for my merch I love
you guys thank you so much for your
support I really hope to see you on the
road folks Joe DeRosa here I'm hitting
the road hitting the big open road with
a bunch of live shows both in New York
and around the country let's start with
the special Very Special salsa windfall
show October 28th at Arlene's grocery
Festival salsa windfall we're doing our
first live show in 25 years we also got
the boys from Czar face esoteric and 7-l
coming down my other podcast will see
you in hell is doing a live show uh and
we've got a bunch of other guests and
surprises happening come on out to that
uh as far as stand-up goes also a
non-traditional stand-up show I'm doing
right here in New York is on November
9th at KGB bar as part of the New York
Comedy Festival I'm doing a show called
selected readings I'll be reading
excerpts from my recently released
audiobook The Penthouse papers and I'll
also be reading some other stuff I've
had published over the years so come on
out to that as far as stand-up goes
I Never Promised You a Rose Garden is on
tour November 11th Philadelphia PA
theater The Living Arts November 17th
Pittsburgh PA bottle rocket Social Hall
November 18th Buffalo New York the
theater at Seneca one November 30th
Denver Colorado the summit December 1st
Phoenix Arizona Crescent Ballroom and
December 3rd Salt Lake City Utah at the
sound well there are more dates coming
soon but get your tickets and show info
and all that good stuff for all the
stuff I just talked about at Joe
derosa.com and of course if you're in
New York City come on down to Joey
Rose's Joey Rose's nyc.com open seven
days a week the and I could be wrong the
crinkle cut fried did your mom do those
when you were a kid in the oven yeah the
ore idle ones I'm sure she did
that's where the kinship when I said
when we we did
against curly fry but we did battle it
and I said I said um there's a Nostalgia
ride with it like sure I hate curlies I
hate curly shoes
everybody I mean like
and I'm not crazy about that they
put on there that's what I'm saying
that's what he said like a black pepper
salt onion powder and garlic powder they
do regular fries at places too like that
it's gross Seasons
[Music]
that's really they're real enough
anyway they do feel a little disagree
unnatural because they put that on
there
I started doing those potato wedges do
that a lot too yeah potato wedges are
gross potato wedges are up there with
home fries just disgusting it's just a
slop pile I mean you invite me here
of course
hash browns King home fries are terrible
but there's a reason for that because
nobody does them right they do the
peppers and the onions and it picks them
up yeah let me tell you what I see when
I think when I see Home Fry I think of a
Barracks that's like Army Food
it's good enough for the Marines it's
good enough for me
all right all right but yeah just so
that's a glimpse into our like that was
like
nine o'clock at night it's the same it's
the same thing and we get in like heated
arguments over things that don't matter
in the history of the world I thought I
thought I was worried last night I
thought we were teetering on an argument
for some reason what holy moly no no no
let me explain let me explain what I
mean see we're not that crazy man
I was worried I didn't think like that
at all I was I had a very long stressful
day because I drove down to Pennsylvania
to do house stuff and I drove back sure
and I was thinking about everything and
I was kind of stressed and when you
started going down the road of like well
we talked about ilios I for a second
thought you were gonna really dig your
heels in and be like I just don't want
to do it I just I I it's just it was an
assumption I was wrong but I thought you
were going to go there and I was like oh
man we're gonna get into an argument now
well when you were pushing soft pretzel
versus hot pocket I was like don't do
this to me because those shouldn't go
against me I wasn't I was going to do it
against a churro
sure yeah we all wanted to take soft
pretzel gotcha yeah so but but anyway
let's do the battle let's get to this
yeah baby waiting for all right time to
b-a-t-t-l-e budge all right guys uh
here's the battle ilios versus Hot
Pockets I am Team Hot Pockets the other
three gentlemen in the room are Elios
now I know I might lose with this and
pimp asked me before why my hot pockets
is a is a is it is a Goliath I just
think they are huge yeah but people love
Elios but pimp ass people for the show
why you like Hot Pockets I said pimp I
gotta be honest with you I'm not crazy
about Hot Pockets but I hate I like a
fight yeah I hate ilios even as a kid I
never once ever had a moment in my life
where I like dealios where I thought
tasted good I never talked to an ilios
where the Box looked attractive to me
from the box to the product to do to the
way it's wrapped in that shitty plastic
what's crazy is everything you're saying
is what I love about what I love about
it I love the box I love the three
perforated slices three on three nine in
the Box I slot it out I put right in the
toaster oven let me tell you something
right now I'm a pizza kid okay I I grew
up around Pizza I love pizza I deliver
pizza for five years almost and I seek
out good pizza I know good pizza I'm
from Staten Island I eat good pizza all
the time something about Elio's Pizza
you might say you know oh it's it's you
know it's crap it's frozen it's Bargain
Basement it's it's listening
it's like how you like I don't know I
want to bring this up because but it's
like the McDonald's burger right it's
not the best burger but there's
something about it sure taste it and
people get addicted to it I think Elios
is so goddamn good it's I think the
sauce is good
I think they offer just pepperoni
there's more now there's a audacity to
start trying to put toppings on this
crap oh you're nuts there's not on
a shingle they serve and they call it
pizza
toppings on it I can't imagine how bad
the meat is they can't even get cheese
sauce and bread right sorry
oh get them get out of here they might
even be owned by the same company yeah
don't cover up your ass don't care Oh
Joe you just can't you can't talk about
the toppings on anilios
I honestly believe I've had 10 in my
life listen as a guy who went through a
big phase of HPS yeah uh they are good
for what they serve breakfast on the Run
maybe I was more of a lunch and dinner
late night guy the pepperoni I get it I
do get it but it's not a real food at
least the pizza the frozen pizza may not
be the best hop where else do you get a
version of a hot box
the concept the construction of it it's
a it's a calzone what do you mean where
do you get a version of that it's a
calzone it's cheese and meat inside of
bread they got a steak in steak is one
they got a ham and cheese one they got a
pepperoni sauce and cheese one but with
Hot Pockets were cold in 2019 in 2020
and 21 glass and plastic fragments yeah
it sounds like a real great okay so so
so so two people found plastic in their
Hot Pockets over the course of three
days come on come on guys this is weak
you you're better than this you're
better than this you're better than this
the cow he's good the calzone I thought
I had them dead the rights and they
don't exist but if you don't mind let me
let me just take a step back but why not
call it calzone calzone is a Hot Pockets
is fun but pizza's Pizza calzones
calzone no but Hot Pockets is fun go
ahead Foley I mean I just wanted to go
back on the first of all they're not
owned by the same company one's
manufactured in Kentucky and the other
one uh jerseys is Lodi New Jersey oh wow
um local boys
are you kidding me I hate the ilios
packaging do it in the hot pocket space
shoot you got to put it into yeah it can
only be supposed to be cooked in a
microwave
I meant the box I'm just saying I hate
every aspect of ilios but you mentioned
the plastic yeah I was saying downtown
it looks like a box of Mufflers because
here's the thing when you get most
frozen pizza when you get it and you
take it out out of its packaging or
whatever if it comes in a box or
whatever usually it's on some sort of
platter it's shrink wrapped it's it's
packaged in a certain way when you get
Elios it is put into these loose baggies
the cheese is falling off of it inside
of the plastic I mean everything
I'm going to tell you I'm going to tell
you why but I'm going to wait that's
going to be the coup de gras
yeah I don't really give it to them but
you got let me guess you get a kick out
of sprinkle in the bag the bag remnants
under the top of the pizza I actually
never did that when I was a kid really
now what would you do it look how good
that looks it's so good
it looks like Italy you got the red you
got the green there's garden vegetables
on there it looks fresh it looks fun
look at that Italian
if I proper off the boat attack it's
beautiful
1963 ilios pizza was founded in Long
Island New York town of Great Neck by
Elias betsios George leolus and Manny
well it looks like Greek people you just
were in Greece let me tell you my
experience with Helios every time I ate
it it was mushy
it was Flavor you put it in yeah
it was flavorless uh the cheese sauce
on it I hate the way that she it never
is just crispy it never has enough
cheese it never is enough cheese and the
cheese is shredded too thin and two
sparsely uh uh uh sprinkled on top that
you don't get enough Cheese look at that
that's and I got that slice in a
restaurant or the pizzeria I'd be like a
restaurant
I would say I would say guys where's the
cheese there's no cheese on this if they
served me a Hot Pocket I said calzone
I'd punch him in the mouth that's true
[Applause]
so you prefer a screaming hot side of a
Hot Pocket with an ice cold center with
a shitty
pocketed baby not once not once not once
that's true that's not true you have the
greatest microwave in the history of
microwaves times has the hot pocket
saved your ass on the road you come back
to that hotel whatever everything is
closed you've worked at that Lobby
Little convenience store and they got
the freezer with hot pockets in it and
you go I can have dinner now never never
I would never go I would eat the shower
cap before no you're full of never
I'd rather have a 7-Eleven Frozen
cheeseburger
shots fired that's nuts how about that
also you're the only app you're forced
to cook it if you're then you're cooking
in the lobby of a Best Western like a
jerk off you get a bag of chips and you
don't
no they usually put a microwave in a
coffee machine a little in a little
fridge in every hotel room that's pretty
standard stuff my microwave
yeah you might be sleeping in a 7-Eleven
now that I think about it
let me tell you something let me let me
tell you something what you said about
the cheese I know what you mean because
you're speaking of Pizza in general but
some people might like something about
ilios they everything they do even if it
is slightly less on the cheese still
works for me it it it is so specific of
what it is and I like the sauce I don't
feel like I'm getting chipped on cheese
I feel it's the perfect amount of
everything I accept it as is and I like
it exactly the way it is they have extra
cheese Elios by the way so that whole
debate is out you just buy extra cheese
well okay but hold on a second that
debate is not out because they didn't
have extra cheesy Elios when we were
growing up and just because they have it
now doesn't mean Elios is suddenly good
we are talking about the core the the
original Elios did you
if you don't mind me asking I would say
these originals are the ham and cheese
and the pepperoni yes yeah yeah
pepperoni pizza I also agree that the
quality of both of those has dipped off
in recent years however Ah that's not
true you don't think so hot pocket yes
Elio's no because they ate a
out of pocket yes
that's a bummer to me that it's dipped
off but I will say you want to talk
about being a kid enjoying something
after school what was better than your
mom having in the freezer a thing that
you cooked and and was a hot it felt
like you were having like a real meal or
something after school it was so
elevated to me but nobody thought that
was a real meal nobody thought that was
elevated 11 it's awesome
and I used to get so many Lean Cuisines
and I swear to you often often I had to
figure out something with my freezer
because it wouldn't all too many yeah
take stuff out of the freezer and leave
it in the fridge to sacrifice
it was every single Lean Cuisine there
was girls come over there like do you
live in a divorce lady
um we'll talk let's talk pillars of the
microwave uh uh Cuisine okay Swanson TV
dinner you know when you're going way
back the Swanson Salisbury steak
absolutely Hot Pockets absolutely Hot
Pockets was one of those but they didn't
come out until later that they weren't
in that first wave that's just like 86
1983. yeah but they didn't start
63. I know we're not talking about I'm
talking about I'm just saying it's it's
staying in a test no time let's see what
Hot Pockets
whoever made those till the 90s
I'm not letting my point get barreled
over okay go ahead I'm saying they are a
pillar of microwave Cuisine up there
with Lean Cuisine and Swanson TV dinners
that's what I said no because you're
comparing a meal to a snack dude as far
as microwave snacks they're the king
dude name me another snack as popular as
a microwave snack it's populous Hot
Pocket I got three words for you Super
Pretzel soft pretzels
come on and you know that those sockets
Pop Tart that's not a microwave food are
you comparing the doors
a food that strictly gets cooked in the
microwave lean only because that's a
that's a beef that's a bad okay but my
question is yet to be answered if you
have a case of Hot Pockets and no
microwave what do you got
you said no a Lean Cuisine is a pill or
the microwave I'm saying Hot Pocket is
too I think you're comparing something
like a Swanson TV dinner to a Hot Pocket
is not I'm saying a Hot Pocket is a
snack name one other microwave snack
like the hot pocket that's that popular
Bagel Bites it's all better we've talked
oven oven you know totinos are better in
an oven you know that Bagel Bites
no other no other idiot would make a
snack that you can only cook in the
microwave cuisine
there's got to be a second option to
Lean Cuisine promise you but my mom used
to throw um my mom used to throw this
The Spinners in the
up they aren't plastic all of our
entrees can be prepared in the microwave
you can only you can't put a cardboard
goddamn thing in the oven it will not
withstand the High sustained heat of the
oven the only reason I'm arguing this
point is because you guys started
sucking on That Lean Cuisine saying it
was a pillar of microwave Cuisine I'm
saying fine it is but a Hot Pocket is
too it is the king snack of the
microwave name me another only
microwavable snack that could compete I
don't think there is another one just
microwavable snack that anybody enjoys
that's what I'm saying there is nothing
nobody enjoys a microwavable somebody's
enjoying it baby what's 40 Years baby
can you name even something semi-close
to uh to a Hot Pocket no no they're the
king no one's even attempting to make
them drosa because they suck nobody dude
that's a that's a dying thing that's
like an AM radio station nobody
breakfast sandwiches microwave only
awesome
awesome awesome
yes what are we saying Jimmy Dean
microwave breakfast
okay yeah corn dogs you got corn dogs
that's all trash secret Foster honey I'm
just trying to find something that could
pepperoni pizza crispy yeah they got it
at number six dude no it's at number
four at eight number one number one okay
so scroll up pip please the mac and
cheese dinner there you go the little
uh craft oh little cups
[Music]
you should drop it because you're not
gonna be my mom you're not beating man
I'm not trying to be mac and cheese but
that's the better life and I'd rather
have a Chef microwave I'm ranking higher
than mac and cheese this is an article
it's an in popular convention
right there on the right Joe we'll blow
a Hot Pocket out of the water oh what's
that sweet lady's name Marie calendar
that's right
speaking to the point I am not saying
there is not another this is a meal
level thing you said a better thing to
be cooked
I'm saying popcorn that Popeye's a snack
Joe no it's done
[Laughter]
[Music]
hungry man's got it on lock since day
one yeah but this is a meal I agree
hungry man is Hungry Man to me is the
king of the microwave the Fried Chicken
Swanson hungry man dinner it cannot be
it can be that was awesome when we were
kids that was a microwave it used to be
it is only micro now because now it's in
the cardboard you come home from school
come home from school right afternoon
I think I almost gave myself a heart
attack this guy was charged up and I
like it he's punching them sheetrock
guys let's talk about factor with the
busy fall season already in swing you
might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals for jam-packed days
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you fuel up fast with
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door you'll save time you'll eat well
and stay on track with your healthy
lifestyle uh I use this I am not a cook
I've said this before I order Factor
comes every Wednesday for me
um it's two everything comes fresh not
frozen takes two minutes to heat it up
in the microwave uh and it's they have I
just chose my my plan for the next week
I choose them every week and what I love
about factors I am somebody who likes to
cook and I still love Factor because I
love it for the convenience and I think
that the meals taste outstanding
especially that they're coming fully
prepared I love that they've got 34 plus
weekly flavor packed fresh never frozen
meals
ready to eat in two minutes I got
Gourmet options they've got uh
vegetarian options they've got uh uh
they've got every option Protein Plus
meals they're cold pressed juices they
also have um smoothies I love it
actually also too they're they've got
breakfast items now like apple cinnamon
pancakes and bacon oh that I didn't know
egg bites nice Factor potato bacon and
egg breakfast skillet and all kinds of
good head to factormeals.com taste buds
five zero and use the code taste buds
five zero to get 50 off that's code
taste buds five zero at factormeals.com
tastebuds five zero to get 50 off
this show is sponsored by better help
folks uh I talk about it all the time I
am somebody that needs a little
assistance in getting through the
day-to-day in tackling the problems I
encounter in life that we all encounter
I'm not special I'm not any different
than anybody else we have hurdles we
need to jump over and sometimes it's
hard to find the solution or the route
or the best approach to jumping over
those hurdles and instead we get stuck
focusing on the hurdles themselves and
that's what I love about better help
it's very convenient it is very
affordable and I have a therapist whom I
really enjoy working with and you know
what if for some reason I wanted to
switch from that therapist it wasn't
working for me anymore you can do that
no questions asked conveniently through
better help it's just great so whether
you're in
or have been in therapy personally uh or
or or haven't or want to try it for the
first time or whatever better help is a
really really great route to to get your
role in in that direction so if you're
thinking about starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
convenient flexible suited to your
schedule you fill out a brief
questionnaire you get matched with the
therapist licensed of course you can
switch them at any time as I said no
additional charge get a break from your
thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds to get today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
betterhelp help.com
tastebuds uh you come home from school
okay midday or you come home from a bar
late at night right okay either way I
have both of those if I'm gonna sit down
and run the television whether I'm
watching cartoons or I'm watching
whatever I'm watching
I'm getting so much more excited for a
try a triple slice yeah
you can start on an end work the middle
go back to a corner and how many and how
many drunks have burnt their houses down
because they forgot the iliosis in the
oven yeah
that's not a thing come on there's a lot
of different factors
two drunk so that he gets over because
they turned the oven on and forgot that
it was on but that's right
a bunch of bozos
when it happens I'm just saying if I'm
drunk I don't want to deal with an oven
I want to deal with a microwave oh yeah
so you're not throw that metal sleeve in
there with the hot pocket leave it on
one minute too long see what happens to
your apartments
I'm dead serious when I say if I'm drunk
I do not want to deal with an oven even
if it's the toaster I don't want to deal
with it a microwave is a better
you forget about it and forget it fine
Baron but I'm drunk and I wanna you're
like the lady in the black and white on
the infomercial yeah I don't know what's
going on
not enough
can I
tired of him
[Laughter]
you want to deal with preheat you want
to deal with fake times
wait I've been off when you're drunk I
don't want to deal with it let's lean
into that without a doubt a food that is
cooked in an oven with a natural fire is
better than a microwave food
that is Baseline not even close come on
you're microwaving 100 of the time we're
cooking it in the oven dude the people
who make you should have went you should
have set the ramifications or the the
qualifications whatever the word is I'll
tell you had to be cooked in a microwave
said is dumb okay
you're putting a silk hat on a pig if
I'm going through all that trouble with
my oven I'm gonna get quality frozen
pizza I'm gonna get a tombstone I'm
gonna get a good frozen pizza
that effort for forgotten Elios
you're drunk you can't drive all you got
is Helios in the freezer what are you
gonna do we need a Hot Pocket to put in
the microwave
that's gonna do
it to me is a lot of effort for the
worst of them guys be honest for a
second you're going to the freezer aisle
sky's the limit we've been honest yes I
live my truth
I think this is personal and we're gonna
get into it a little bit don't forget
let's walk down
I want all the lights on I want a
grocery store to be wasting so much
energy and money
as possible what I want in bright red
apples out I want the place 32 degrees I
want the aisles four lanes long and I
wanted and brightest yes that's why
so when I walk in there in the summer in
a wet bathing suit and a little bit of
sunburn on me you're just like makes you
dig a little USA yeah let's go
yeah what part of town do you live in uh
in Astoria okay because I live Lower
East Side okay Metro acres is a gross
grocery store on the Lower East Side all
right guys I you nine if we can all
get on the same page for a second
full Suburban grocery store on the Lower
Side full double-sided freezer aisle man
that's what I'm talking about desserts
one side Savory on the other I have to
avoid that aisle at all cost because I
will fall dude everything from Full Deli
counter
fresh break baked rolls that whole set
it is a full Suburban grocery list
I'm liberal with how long I keep the
doors open too it looks like dry ice
when I close it frozen sauce it's got to
open it oh wait about five ten minutes
see what's in there exactly if I don't
see fog on the door I never even open
100 yeah please the uh but I'm saying
this back to the freezer
sky's the limit Daddy Warbucks takes you
in there he says kiddo welcome to I've
saved you from the orphanage sure you
can have anything you want that freezer
aisle as long as it's Pizza am I 37.
that's my Disney World
I'm dying of cancer
that's a fast pass you're picking Helios
you got the array of everything all the
frozen pizzas sky's the limit get anyone
you want you're picking Elio hold on
should I can I put a pin in that are you
picking Hot Pockets well that's a no
hold on
as good as guests have been no other
guests get into the argument like this
they are they have good points they I
mean the retorts are no lies it's gonna
be crazy
you guys play this better than we do but
you but you you Hot Pockets or hot
pockets that's it Helios is Helios
not no no you said yourself that my food
is its only thing that it doesn't exist
I think you proved me wrong you dumb
dumb okay but tell me another Frozen
brand of Hot Pockets then tell me a
competing Hot Pocket devour what's
devour yeah look it up
I could be wrong but I hope this sticks
that's come on give me something give me
something here
it's microwavable food The Valor sounds
like some kind of laxative
that other one pulled it up there was
corn dogs
what pizza is a category sure you have
an option of any frozen pizza no matter
how pricey are you picking hot pots
I'm really asking are you picking I'm
being dead serious yes yes at time not
all the time because I like variety
sometimes I'm in the mood for a DiGiorno
sometimes I like a tombstone sometimes I
like the little totinas the thin ones
that they're almost unlike if he's
feeling like Mozza bread I've had a mama
Celeste in my lifetimes I'll grab a
french fry Joe don't leave stuff
it's a Friday night and Golden Girls are
on it there's a sale on Diet Pepsi yeah
I might grab it yeah
because they play at least four episodes
back then I might get a v of an Editor
to go with it
can I tell you what I've done with
stuffers I've gotten it I've added my
own meat to it that's all right I never
liked that
that is the Cadillac
that's the Cadillac it's on French bread
it's just so different man when that hit
everybody he was like what the
don't know what Elias is
you're literally getting excited and
showboating on a technicality if we lose
because they don't know it all right you
can't win on your own all that matters
is winning we're gonna we're gonna lose
it's that good wait it's only
sold in the Northeast and it's still
like top seven or eight in total frozen
pizza sales in the country but wait a
minute hold on wait yeah we're a
boutique operation Joe we're not mass
producers
wait a second where are you getting that
statistic from no that's true I was
doing research last night you jerk off
yeah
our pockets are deep voice
top ten listen to me it's on the
Wikipedia page I also think Elio stands
alone I really do I don't really I don't
really put it in the category of the
tombstone if you're in the mood you're
not in the if you're in the mood for
Elias you're not in the mood I'll just
tell you another reason I don't like
ilios how are we on time pimp do we get
a wrap
okay great I'm going to tell you another
reason I don't like Elios and I feel
like this is maybe a Philly thing or
Jersey Philly Regional okay
I've I see sometimes I see uh um uh uh
for God's sake Sicilian pizza in New
York I do not see it anywhere near the
to the extent that I used to see it in
Philly of course it was so prevalent in
Philly so it's tomato pie yes which if
you don't know which is square slices
with just tomato sauce and sometimes
some sprinkled Parmesan it's great I
know it yeah
I ever got it was that was at a deli in
Staten Island they had a version of it
at the counter wrapped up yeah well I
get by the way got to do a shout out
core police Bakery he's a big fan are
you kidding me they're tomato
pie their tomato pie is better than most
Pizza I shout them out all the time what
up baby every day
[Music]
shout outs to Collegeville Italian
bakery too McDonald's
he's got your childhood and pastries
core police is unbelievable yeah they're
strawberries they do a strawberry
shortcake
you show up to somebody's house in
Philly with that Strawberry Shortcake
because because we're because we're poor
we don't we feel bad so we gotta bring
your Strawberry Shortcake but this dude
I have a good point actually Sicilian
was so prevalent and tomato pie was was
was prevalent enough but Sicilian I'll
stick with that was so prevalent that
when you ordered pizza on Friday night
you had to discuss are we doing Sicilian
or doing really no we did not as a kid
that was never on the table
yeah my dad will get Cecilia at least it
was less ordered but it was always like
you oh
this is my favorite slice do I want to
say that but as a kid that was never
wrong
traditional Sicilian but my point is is
it was so it was served so it was so
much a part of the menu that it was
actually brought up in New York you've
never even ask the question I feel like
okay for the most part I'll give you
that uh
that's not a knock on New York I'm just
saying like I'm just I'm just bringing
up a point with Elios that
experience and this might not be fair of
tomato pie from cor police and Sicilian
pizza that was really good all the time
I think is what tainted ilios to me I
understand is a version of that it was a
version of either one of the worst
version
I knew it was personal yeah
I was older you've never had a counselor
we had strombolis calzones are in New
York thing
calzone
sweet peppers and onions sweet pepper
and onions
here's what I think and tell me
the reason I'm being nice to him is
because we finally got to the bottom of
it I knew it was a childhood trauma
thing okay I knew that's what it was I
knew that's what the beef with the ilios
was is that why you were saying this was
personal yes I thought you meant me
fighting you was personal between you
and me I was like what the what does he
mean by that Jesus
[Laughter]
okay just check with them make sure we
didn't do Leo's last time here we go
all right leave me alone also I do want
to mention as a kid because I was
younger when Elio's head was was buzzing
in the early 90s as was Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles I don't know if you
remember I'd be remiss if I didn't bring
this up they did a hot collab where you
would get on every bar every back of the
Alias Elio's pizza box it then turned
into the mask of one of the Teenage
Turtles as a seven year old I
get to eat frozen pizza
come on let me tell you this Elios was
such that even the turtles could
lure me in and I loved those damn
Turtles
I'm gonna say this and I
well looks so good
how much did having Ninja Turtles do for
pizza yeah they really kept the ball and
not enough said about that Ninja Turtles
Ninja Turtles are to pizza with Cypress
Hill and Dr Dre are to weave
people loved it but man they kicked it
they really connected they made you
wanted a pizza so bad I mean they made
it seem like you could just grab a slice
and go like oh I'm just I'm on my
skateboard I'm eating pizza I'm in the
silver yeah
it's a way of life yeah you want to be
like a ninja skateboarder you probably
will throw down pizza here and there
yeah snack yeah
um I will say this I I TR and I truly
mean this you're gonna tell me no but I
don't think I've ever heard someone say
they don't like ilios other than him
sure have you ever heard of Emilio's
denier never and ever and this is what I
wanted to say that
as a kid okay as a crucible the reason
that the packaging was so loose is so
that the kids when they came home by
themselves they could they could get it
out and throw in the microwave and have
something to eat that complex thing full
package that they that they have dude
that in a microwave is is the worst
thing ever I understand
if you had both parents working and then
this is why Elios are so close to
everybody's heart and I don't know what
your parents did foreign there was no
way that my mom was getting five
dollar or six dollar uh two per pack
yeah that was the problem the only two
Helios was 87 cents
I could see the family on a budget
that's why everybody
I love I love snapping them he would do
the boxes of nine not nine individuals
we would do the big industrial bot it
was like a big cardboard box of three
three packs wow let me just put them out
oh that's nice I only did you live in a
quarry
's pretty well
that was the other thing I hated about
it was when I would try to break them
apart it would always break uneven and
you'd have the one piece the whole three
wow this is what you're doing
yeah
I would break them before no you cook
them together because I think I only
wanted two oh my God this guy is
sleeping over my house
there was a coming-of-age story when you
got to eat the whole one because I was
like four or five they would be making
that I'd get one maybe two whatever when
I was able to eat and make my own thing
that was like that was like puberty for
me also so you could eat a box and get
away with it oh yeah I've eaten a box
I'm sure I've eaten the Box
[Laughter]
it's great it's great this has been this
has been great I don't even know Elio's
pizza but I'm voting for it over nuclear
pocket whoa love that that's how shitty
your product is wow that says and listen
I do want I do kind of want to meet in
the middle I was a bit there was a high
school and college big hot pocket even
lean pocket when I was watching my
figure that's how that's how big I'm in
the realm here that's what I wanted to
ask you that was a lit like we never got
Hot Pockets not his kids
this was mainly College I never had them
I just had them later lately late in
life a couple times I bought the
breakfast ones for on the go Burgers so
I'm I'm at a lot I do I do enjoy the
chicken parm one the lean chicken parm
pocket I thoroughly enjoyed
but it was I gotta be honest it was
never cooked correctly never once I told
you it was nice
I'm already I'm already negating half of
the comments anybody going Hot Pockets
if you like to burn yourself learn how
to not touch a hot thing wait for 10
seconds and let it cool
everybody
[Music]
know what's going on inside that calzone
all right so my my apologies to then the
people saying they burn themselves okay
my apology uh they're both depressing
but Helios is a Dark Void that light
doesn't escape from as a kid acceptable
as an adult worrisome dude it's good
dude
and tongue again any day for a Hot
Pocket if I can if I went home today
because I haven't bought uh ilios in a
long time and my ladies never bought
them and I don't have them in the house
it's been since I lived probably with my
parents and I if I went home today and
she decided for some reason to get them
and I opened the freezer and didn't know
they were there and I opened them they
were there
the Yelp that I would come out of your
body I would just do it I would do a you
know I would be genuinely happy like oh
yeah throw it in the oven and have it
immediately yeah throw it in the oven
yeah yeah put a little parm cheese on
there a little bit of garlic salt
whatever you like and you feel like
you're getting a lot it feels good I
know it goes up yeah
ilios if you eat SpaghettiOs into
adulthood you're disgusting monster It's
Hot Pockets all day well that's rude
yeah SpaghettiOs are great
vote defaults to Hot Pockets because
I've never even heard of Elio's Pizza
um various entenmanns for bro breakfast
ilios for dinner they're the perfect
guests great time with the bozos
yes shout out to the bows was always
there for us richer poor delivering the
delicious cheesy school lunch style
that's the other reason
the first blazing hot bite to the icy
middle bite that's the other reason I
didn't like Elio's it reminded me of
like cafeteria at high school or
Hospital Pizza they didn't do good food
at your high school my high school did
killer food Believe It or Not except the
pizza sucked because a lot of a lot of
schools or like mass per you know like
hospitals did a very shitty version of
the square Elio's Pizza you know what
they really do they really did a
disservice
I'm not kidding cheese fries with the
whiz and cheesesteaks every day
uh let's before we go to the the actual
uh Humble Pie segment guys I think you'd
like to plug the Pod anything else Tour
by the way big guy uh we're on tour
right now the state trashy tour you can
get tickets at rdgarverage.com
um yeah and check out the podcast on
YouTube and whenever you listen to pots
yes and the homies yeah thanks for being
here I can't recommend their podcast and
they'll show enough you guys have both
done it multiple times within the past
year you're available
[Music]
it looks like the funnest thing thank
you very much I appreciate love you guys
we appreciate you so much all right by
the way get the tickets now because
you're selling out all over yeah the
shows are selling out so it's great
check out the taste buds merch go to
nopressnetwork.com uh you know subscribe
on YouTube and no pressure uh follow us
on on Spotify rate US on iTunes please
we haven't been saying that for a while
but we could really use it hit that like
button hit that alert button my tickets
are on sale
um yes our tickets are on sale jojo.com
right yep salvocano comedy.com my
special taping at the Vic in Chicago on
December 2nd is on sale right this
second if you want to get that and uh
yeah that's pretty much it let's go to
the phones here pimp is taking the ilios
drum roll oh
especially that that only tells me that
Elios did outperformed
they were fighting a national brand yeah
we got Hot Pockets guys for the
listeners we got hot pockets in a 56.4
percent and Elio's Pizza in a
43.6 take it we'll take it I'll take it
I didn't know that uh Elio's because of
the team I don't think it is regional it
is it's only the Northeast but how did
they get Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles as
a part of it it's such a good product
because a lot of little Philly dirt tags
it could have just been a regional ads
though hey we'll have this one we'll
have one in the South one I just feel
like if I just feel like that's a wild
uh get yeah you know but I guess you
know Shaq does Insurance commercials
that are Regional to like Atlanta sure
yeah yeah sure anyway folks we I still
love all three yeah
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them